honestly building a cat Fork with
someone is one of the most intimate
experiences Oh two or three humans can
share together hi my name is Jack and
we're at my apartment what we're doing
today is we're gonna build the world's
greatest cat board for my cat Jenkins
this is Jenkins current cap this little
tree in no way represents what Jenkins
deserves Jenkins gives and gives and
gives and all he does is different I
feel like a cat with a heart that big
deserves a home to match we're all
prepped everyone is here we've got all
this stuff and it's just the right time
because every day at this time Jenkins
takes a long nap we're gonna have to be
very very quiet so we don't wake him up
but I think we're gonna get this done
before cat nap time is over
I'm excited guys let's do this Oh
hi I'm Tanner I'm helping Jack build the
cat fort my name is summer and here to
make sure that any cat involved in this
sport has a good time do we have an
unboxing yeah
we've got a lot of cardboard Jenkins has
a one lifelong passion and that is a
passion for cardboard I think it's gonna
be really really excited
want to have a periscope coming out of
here so you can get in and focus little
head out so here's what I'm doing is I'm
making a shelf that's gonna sit on the
inside of a box so you can jump up and
jump out the roof of the box I've got
two triangle shape pieces they both got
slits cut in them to kind of slide in
there I am slightly worried because we
have a huge amount to do including
building a courtyard and putting
crenellations and decorations on all of
this stuff ventilation is what you see
on battlements of a castle that goes
like this so I'm creating a little
crenellations station here so that we
can have some of this stuff all around
the side of the floor we need one more
here all right are you gonna have it go
hot tensions are a little bit high my
main thing is I hope that Tanner's not
this pleased with me he said it was
gonna be bad at this and he didn't want
to trust me with a job so well this is
the best I can do he doesn't like it
all right very good job good
well I kind of lost my win there for a
little bit I thought we weren't gonna
get this thing done but I think we're
gonna do this okay the cat is about to
wake up we've got five maybe ten more
minutes and we're lucky and we have so
much more to do I don't know if we're
gonna be able to make it in time before
he gets out of there
okay so we're finally finished this is
the completed structure here's what we
have we have a big skull right on the
entrance which is to intimidate
Jenkins's enemies but do not intimidate
Jenkins because he's a very brave boy
everything in the in the courtyard here
is centralized around this one pole it's
wrapped with rope so Jenkins can really
scratch on and if he needs to but it's
also got a lot of string hanging down so
it can play and bad at the string he can
get inside onto a big step that's built
up in there get on to the top where he
can look at his drawbridge he can go
inside one of these boxes and look out
of his periscope or it can relax in this
lovely for Jenkins right on the far east
side of them this is a finished cap for
maybe time to wake Jenkins up and see
what he thinks of it let's get Jenkins
is good we're about to bring him in this
is gonna be his first reaction to the
fort
I don't know what to expect